Back by not so popular demand meaning
about one third of my viewers love these
videos and the other two thirds are
like,
it's another episode of mystery
languages.
I will give you some samples of a
language and you have to guess what
language it is.
You might not be able to get the exact
language,
but maybe you'll be able to guess the
language family or the region or country
where that language is spoken or
something like that.
Just try to see how close you can get
language number one,
please listen.
Sherry did see a movie.
I did some despite the rotarians.
Yeah I do my lesson but even this one
more to me hit me.
She Rung,
we lead poison.
Nobody can witness.
She should go going back.
Yaba [inaudible] and you know,
cause he,
I did some Misha here wasn't,
it was cynical about very,
now let's see a written sample of that
language.
So what language do you think it is?
The language is Yoruba.
Yoruba is a member of the Niger Congo
language family and is spoken in the
west African countries of Nigeria and
Beneen as well as Togo.
It's an official language in Nigeria and
to spoken by an estimated 30 million
people.
Current estimates are based on
population growth since 1990 when 18
million people spoke it as a native
language.
It's also the most widely spoken African
language outside of Africa,
spoken by migrants around the world,
and that's excluding Arabic,
which is not considered a native
language of Africa.
You'll robot is primarily the language
of the Yoruba people,
but not all Yoruba people speak the euro
by language.
Yoruba is a tonal language and each
syllable has one of three tones,
high,
mid,
or low.
And as I understand it,
you can hear these three tones in the
name of the language,
which is pronounced Yoda with a mid,
low and high tone.
I probably just slaughtered that
pronunciation,
but you get the idea.
There are three tones.
Another feature to notice is that Yoruba
syllables consist of a vowel,
a consonant,
followed by a vowel or a nasal sound
that functions as its own syllable.
There are no consonant clusters,
and in that regard,
it's similar to Japanese.
All right,
let's look at another language.
Please listen.
[inaudible] oh this.
Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] know sending it.
You go tubing in a Nigga Ya Kay up in
the head on the hen to it.
Uh,
and the Doh Doh,
Doh,
Doh.
Just your don't need [inaudible] hillel.
Oh No.
Oh no,
because if we just say it's a buy
nowadays.
[inaudible].
Now let's see a written sample of this
language now.
What language do you think it is?
The language is Navajo.
Navajo is a member of the southern
branch of the Athabaskan language
family.
It's one of the most widely spoken
native American languages with around
170,000
native speakers,
most of whom are bilingual and speak
English as well.
The area where Navajo is spoken is in
the southwestern United States,
principally in Arizona,
but also across the state borders in New
Mexico and Utah.
Navajo is a tonal language with four
tones.
Hi Lo rising and falling.
It has a large inventory of consonant
sounds.
One example is a distinction between
plan stops and fricatives and labial
stops and fricking tips.
For example,
there's the plane stop cut and there's
the labor.
You'll stop quit.
The difference is that the labial sounds
include the rounding of the lips.
Another example is and whoa and end,
whoa,
these two sounds are sounds not used in
English,
and then we have the labial sounds as
well.
Those are just a few of the many sounds
of Navajo.
Okay.
Time for the next language.
What am I knew?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] have
to get on with summary or moving them
cause some symptoms or what they want to
put you on [inaudible] because we put
down and sort of new car or domain.
How last point you had to show my money,
so he stood up to him and I've got a
steak or something.
I'd or quartermaine.
Yeah.
Now let's see a written sample.
Okay.
All right.
What language do you think it is?
It's the Hungarian language.
Hungarian is spoken by around 15 million
people.
Most of them in Hungary,
in central Europe,
but some live in neighboring Romania as
well as other nearby countries like
Slovakia,
Slovenia,
Austria,
Serbia,
Croatia,
and Ukraine.
Hungarian is not an Indo European
language.
It's a member of the eugric branch of
the erotic language family.
One notable feature of Hungarian is that
there are lots of germinated consonants,
germinated,
meaning long consonants that are held
longer than a short consonant.
These are represented in writing by
double letters in the audio sample.
You can hear this if you pay attention
for a little pauses when the consonants
are linkedin.
Another notable feature is palatalized
consonants such as Chia.
Yeah,
and yeah,
and overly simple way of describing
these sounds is to say that they sounded
like the consonant followed by a year
sound.
I hope you liked this episode of mystery
languages.
If you haven't seen the previous four
episodes,
be sure to check those out.
They're pretty much the same as this
one,
but with different languages.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen.
Who are my top tier patrion supporters.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.